我們今天就直接講重點
我們要怎麼樣去建立
我們的一個日內交易
首先我們直接看到我們的日線
我把圖都放得很大
今天
你要觀察的是什麼
你今天想要幹嘛
你不曉得你要做多還是要做空
我們一開始根本不曉得你要做多還是做空
所以你要先建立的是什麼
我今天
要做哪個方向
我們今天的情況下
我們就只講我們走到了晚上了
昨天假设我们下午5点之后看盘
一天只有走6跟4小时
他今天已经走了2跟到3跟了
基本上一天的行情都已经走一半了
晚上的行情大概率你就只能挑一个方向来做
所以你今天要记得一件事情
我今天要做哪一个方向
我们就以纽约盘晚上6点之后
我们晚上6点之后在观察盘面的时候
你就要很笃定一件事情
我今天要做哪个方向为主
我这边就一个带
第一个要做拖还是做空
昨天晚上我們做了一筆小的空單
我們要去知道一件事情
當早上已經拉了
K棒下來了
並且他中午到下午的時候他沒有收回去
那大概率呢
今天的行情的方向是直接要向下的
大概率他會向下
我給大家一個重點就是
只要是亞洲盤早上8點到12點
這裡一開盤直接有拉量拉下來的話
並且
他晚上6點之前他都沒有收回來
晚上6點之前 像這裡就一個安例
晚上之前他都沒有收回來
就代表延續走勢的概率很高什麼叫延續走勢的概率很高今天你要知道一件事情我們講的延續走勢的概率很高就是要來探討這根日線它會收紅色的
代表它收不回來
連開盤都收不回來
它只會收一根完美的紅K
所以你現在來判斷
早上
這是第一種情況
你把它記下來
這一定要記下來
早上8點到12點如果有拉量
如果往上衝
延續走勢的概率就高達90%
如果今天往下衝一拉量的
尤其是開盤8點到9點一拉量
就篤定好方向的
基本上已經很難再收回去了
基本上是已經很難再收回去了
高概率會幹嘛
高概率都會繼續往下收
我們往下收的重點是在於說
今天是日線往下收呢
還是哪一邊往下收
到底是日線往下收還是哪一邊往下收
為什麼
因為你看這裡
8點往下
目前的日線是收紅色
但重點來了
我們大概率都知道
它會收紅色高達90%
但是收下影線還是收飽滿的日K
因為他有可能收成這樣
到最後收成這樣
收成一個什麼
長下癮的
紅K
就不是收成什麼
飽滿的紅K
所以
當早上到下午的時候
他
要
早上開盤
直接往下灌
確定好方向做空了
再來我們要確定
要確定成交量密集的地方
因為那邊往往很有可能會來收收盤價
所以要記得我們要來預測
最後大部分都要預測收盤價
我們要來一個重點就是我們要回來預測我們的收盤價在哪裡我們是不是已經大概知道方向了那我們現在為什麼要來預測有可能的收盤價那就是因為要讓你知道抓到某一小段價倉就差不多該停了
你不要認為說今天它有可能高概率往下逛
今天我們這裡發現
這裡有線形圖
並且這裡有拉量下跌
並且有三根拉上來
這裡很明顯就是一個成交量很密的地方
都非常有可能收盤價再拉回來這裡
你要想
有量的地方
有密集的地方
就是我常常在盘口里面常常讲的
有量的地方
它会形成真强或假强
那这些其实都不是太大重点
重点就是在于说
因为这里有很大的成交量
所以往往价格会被往上吸
尤其是在这种
在今天以内时间很短暂
你只要有大额订单在那里
收盘价格会被往上吸
或者是打一个主量
挂单时间快一点
主量挂在那边
它定在那里
收盘价也很容易被它拉回来
所以你现在要做一件事情
叫做预测收盘价
你不是去预测说
我今天下个月往下到多少
懂得吗
因为我们根本不晓得
它到底会往下冲到多少
第一个我们知道方向了
但是很多人会误会一个重点
是说我不晓得会往下多少
我自己都常常跟大家讲
是说我以太币
我做日内的交易
我有抓40点到60点
其实就差不多
比特币我只要抓个300点
400點500點以上有可能就會平倉
抓個30點以上
可以套利就可以平倉掉
或者是你就看大概率的波動
到這裡的波動聽聽看
上下都大概30點到40點
今天如果在上面進場有下去的40點50點就可以平倉掉因為大概率收盤下來都有可有很有可能拉回來這裡這個是第一個有可能拉回來收盤的位置
所以你在這邊做交易的時候你要去觀察
雖然我們要做空
但是你要記得一件事情
目前現階段成交量比較密的地方是被定在中間的
很容易被吸又被吸回來
很容易被吸星大法又不要幹嘛
吸到上面來
所以你在做交易的時候你知道方向了
再來去預測收盤價
你要去預測收盤價
預測收盤價很有可能被拉回來的位置
尤其是在這種六日行情波動較小的時候
你都已經知道今天是六日了
或者是禮拜六
你看到晚上有可能行情較小
那你就可以大概去預測收盤價
那或者是禮拜天
今天是禮拜天
那你今天就可以預測禮拜天
這跟周限的收盤價大概定在哪裡
所以我常講今天禮拜天
那你就大概知道要收周限
那你開始要預測
它有可能周限會收在哪裡
今天是禮拜五
那你凌晨在做交易的時候
你是不是就要觀察
今天凌晨
他有可能今天晚上会收盘收在哪里
你可能做最后一根4小时
或做最后一根8小时
或做月线的时候
你是不是也要看最后一周
最后一周K线要干嘛
最后一周K线
他有可能收月线会被定在哪里
这个还是比较重要的
所以说你要常常去知道一件事情
现在什么时间点
该做什么事
现在能量波动小
其实你不是在预测多远
你在预测说
大概率有可能收盘价
收回到哪裡 可能還比較重要一點
這是第一個 尤其是昨天的禮拜六
你要來預測收盤價會哪裡
我們大概知道 這裡是有量的位置
有可能收盤價會收回來這裡
可能一根引線就被訂回來了
基本上這裡就是我們今天要找的關鍵價格